hi everyone my name is peter brodin i'm
a pediatrician
a pediatric immunology consultant at the
kurdistan university hospital
as well as an immunologist working at
the kerlinski institute
and the science for life laboratory i'm
also the director for the national mass
cytometry facility
at the science for life laboratory here
in stockholm sweden
i'm going to talk about systems level
amino monitoring from acute to recovery
phase of severe covet 19
and present the recent preprint from my
lab
as well as our collaborators
so i'm going to present today our recent
work on covid19
in patients with severe disease using
systems-level immune monitoring methods
to monitor acute recovery phases
in such patients and this is a
collaborative project between my
research group here at kerlinski
institute in stockholm sweden
and colleagues in finland at the
helsinki university hospital
so the rationale for this work that we
have taken
is based on some recent studies we've
done in
other in healthy individuals as well as
various disease cohorts
and it's on the idea that by
longitudinally monitoring the immune
system patient
we are able to understand relationships
between cells and proteins
that give rise to various disease
manifestations
and and by by taking advantage of this
longitudinal monitoring
we can infer from changes that occur
over time in cellular
activation states protein measurements
in the blood and so on
we can infer relationships between these
different features in the immune system
of a human this allows us to
better understand these processes it
also allows us to see
differences between groups of patients
that are not
visible at individual time points
or snapshots in time
so this is something that we we do quite
a bit and we have applied also
in this case to call with 19 patients
um another thing that we have taken
advantage of
is recent developments from my research
group and other research groups
to allow whole blood to be analyzed as
the primary source of cells and proteins
rather than the traditional pbmc's
peripheral blood mononuclear cells the
benefit of using whole
blood as shown by this paper published
in immunity
2019 is that by preserving blood
directly at collection sites the
technical sources of variation are
minimized
we also this also allows us to capture
all the cells present in the blood not
only the fraction
of mononuclear cells traditionally
analyzing
and which allows us to get a more
complete representation
of the peripheral blood immune system in
patients
the fact that we can minimize the
technical sources of variation
which are associated by with pbmc
preparation normally also allows us to
see more biological signal
and we find that to be particularly
useful when working with patient samples
and doing these kind of longitudinal
monitoring studies so what i'm going to
do today is i'm going to talk you
through
this recent study that me and my
collaborators have
performed in patients with severe
covid19
where we monitor longitudinal blood
samples from 39
patients and this was recently uh
uploaded as a preprint for med archive
on june 5th and is readily available
through that website so
the logic here and the approach that we
took was to
enroll kovi 19 patients admitted to the
hospital
in helsinki and synden these patients
have
variable severity and we
sought out to understand the immune
response
ongoing in these patients and and trying
to understand
um what determines disease severity
but also just get a natural course of
the immune response
using these systems level tools
and and for me systems immunology is all
about
understanding how immune cells
communicate with one another
how they relate and coordinate their
efforts
um and and give rise collectively to
an immune response or an immunopathology
and and one and one powerful method to
to do that and to understand all of
these different cell types is to use
mass cytometry
so we used mass cytometry to profile the
cellular component of the blood immune
system
um and we also used all link assays
which is one of many
methods to profile large numbers of
plasma protein
with very good accuracy and mass
cytometry
as i'm sure many of you know is based
upon using metals with
sorry antibodies using metal tags
and rare earth metal probes and and
the oleg assays are based on antibodies
but
in this case coupled to oligotail
and two different antibodies need to
recognize a given protein
giving minimal background signal and
very high accuracy
so we we apply this to this cohort and
um as i'll show you here these are the
this is
basically the cohort 39 patients
and this shows the study day so this was
a very rapid response
kind of study where we tried to get as
much samples collected in the shortest
amount of time
to be able to quickly report on
the immune response and the
immunopathology to help
clinical colleagues to devise better
immunomodulatory
therapies which is an urgent need for
for these severe patients
given the fact that most of the deaths
actually occur as a consequence of
immunopathology
and so in this cohort there was no
immunomodulatory therapies given and
instead we we took this approach to try
to
map out the natural course of the immune
response in this patient
and as you can see from this chart which
is a little bit complicated you can see
across this represent
siteof or samples collected for mass
cytometry
circles denote samples collected for
plasma
protein analysis and um and also
antibody estates and so on
um and you can see that many of these
samples
overlap but sometimes the days differ a
little bit due to logistical challenges
in the intensive care unit
we also have a group of patients in
black here which are the
patients that recovered from disease and
give us a view of the recovery state
after severe profit 19
which will be which i will discuss a
little bit
so um what we really sought out to do
as i said is to try to understand what
happens
in patients from the time of admission
with severe kobe 19
until recovery and this gives you
an overview of some of the parameters
that are changing
obviously initially the patients come in
with high fevers
as shown in the top left graph
and this fever subsides over the course
of 10 to 20 days
usually in these patients and
there's also a very well described
lymphopenia that is seen in these
patients
and previous reports have even suggested
that the degree of lymphopenia
correlates with disease severity and we
also see that lymphocyte
counts as well as white blood cell
counts
recover over the course of the same time
frame from from admission
to about 20 days after that
in in parallel with these changes are
reductions in cytokines
such as gamma il-6
which are well-known pro-inflammatory
cytokines obviously
associated with a number of different
diseases and previously also reported to
be
elevated in kovic 19 patients
i should also show or explain that these
two colors represent patients
treated currently in the icu and
patients treated in a normal ward
usually we denote all of these patients
are severely ill
they're all requiring oxygen support
but the non-icu patients differ in the
sense that they
typically breathe without a ventilator
while the icu patients
are all ventilated we also show
on the right the levels measured in the
recovered patients
to indicate sort of when these
acutely sick patients reach the level
seen in recovered patients and those
patient
levels typically are
on par with healthy individuals
so some of the some notes about how this
study was
conducted we as i said we we try to
perform a very quick study to be able to
quickly report on the immune response in
severe korean 19 because there's a
important to communicate this
information as quickly as possible so we
can
better treat these patients and one
thing that really helped us to to do
this rapidly was the fact that we were
able to go
from sample acquisition on the mass
cytometer
to data within just
one day and the way we do that is that
we have
been able to develop a system for
classifying in
individual cells into 62
known subpopulations of cells and this
is done using an algorithm which is
based on
basically a learning algorithm where we
have trained
a learning algorithm to recognize these
different cell types
as manually classified using a
system that we are currently writing up
and we'll communicate very shortly
um so that allows us to go from acquired
mass cytometry data
to these files that we could analyze
within one day
and what we found is obviously very
dynamic changes across a range of
different immune cell populations
that's maybe not so surprising
but and this is a very complicated slide
obviously and for details i refer to the
the published or the submitted preprint
but some of the changes that i want to
point out are for example in the top
left corner the decrease in neutrophils
which is seen over time um as well as
some important increases in eosinophils
as well as dendritic cell subpopulations
both the cd1 cdcs the cd11c
dcs and the plasma cycle disease all
show a increase and
suggesting that these populations are
suppressed or depleted somehow
in the acute phase of cobit 19.
we also see uh transient plasma blast
expansion which is
uh reported previously also by others
and it's a known phenomenon during acute
immune responses
and i will get back to that in a little
bit
and and when it comes to the t-cell
populations i would like to point out
the fact that
most of the populations that see which
dramatically increase over the course of
acute
immune responses um are either
memory phenotype t-regs but also mostly
these terminally differentiated
uh effector and central memory effect
central memory and effective memory
piece of many of them expressing the
cd57 marker
so uh obviously a lot more details here
but i would
suggest that interested readers should
check out the preprint for more detail
another thing that we found quite
intriguing given the fact that
not so many previous reports had focused
on innate cells and
was a pretty clear pattern seen
for eosinophils and what we found in
particular was
that over the course of this acute
disease
here's highlighted by one representative
patient
we saw a transient expansion of
eosinophils expressing the cd62l
homing factor and this is a pretty
intriguing because
previous reports from other diseases
have shown that such
penicillin dd62l
home to the lung and and
some reports have suggested that they
can be regulatory
in the lung while others have suggested
that they might be pro-inflammatory and
driving
immunopathology in the lung and we see
these cells
the system we've used here is a
clustering algorithm
um it's it's uh and and
so this is an automated uh clustering
approach it's an
unsupervised method and and it's a
pretty clear expansion
scene for the cd62l expressing
eosinophils between days two and four
um what's also interesting is that
this coincides with a uh with a high
interference gamma level
in plasma and internal gamma has been
reported previously to
induce such an up regulation of cd62
uh on hills and fields so we think that
this represents
an axis that might be involved in
immunopathology in the lung
of these patients which typically occurs
around
day six to seven after admission
so uh this this phenomenon that we have
seen
here precedes um sort of predates that
usual severe sort of deterioration
that typically occurs with development
of acute respiratory distress syndrome
and so on
on day seven or so as for the adaptive
cells this is a very busy slide
and i'm showing you four different cell
types which are the total b
cells the e c fours and t cells as well
as the gamma delta details which are
quite few in numbers the thing i wanted
to point out here is predominantly the
plasma blast expansion which is shown on
the left there in the b
cell column and that seems to occur
typically within the first four or five
days or so after admission
we see that the kinetics of the plasma
blast response varies a little bit
between patients but it usually occurs
during the first five days after
admission we also see
a transient t-reg cell expansion of
the cd4 columns and another thing that i
think is interesting to point out
which is not seen in all patients but
certainly in this patient
is that they are basically the cd4
population is
split into two um and and
the what differs between those two uh
sub populations of cd4
is basically the cd4 expression itself
and we don't have any clear explanation
for why
the subset of cd4 t cells down regulate
their cd4 expression
but some other reports previously have
indicated that perhaps
pd4 t cells that are directly infected
by viruses
can sometimes down regulate their cd4
expression
and and we don't know if these patients
have
had an infection of their cd4 t cells
but but one possible hypothesis proposed
by others
for severe called 19 involves
antibody dependent enhancement where
fc receptor mediated infection would
occur
and so that is possible and and maybe
the cd4
down regulation represents that but this
is purely speculative at this moment
um yes another thing that we
um often try to do is to try to assess
the uh differences or the relationships
between different cell types
and and what we've done here is we've
basically performed the correlation
analysis between different immune cell
populations
and we see that the cell populations
that are correlated both positively
correlated and negatively correlated
over the course of time
differs between different stages of the
disease
for example in the beginning we see that
there's a pretty large block in the
lower left
corner there of cell types that are
positively
associated with one another and
negatively associated with the new
field which probably is related to the
fact that
there is a shift in the neutrophil to
lymphocyte
ratio have been proposed by others to
also correlate with disease severity
and then over the different course at
the stages of the disease
uh course we see that different cell
types
are co-regulated we interpret this as
cell populations that are strongly
correlated are probably regulated by
some common
uh factor or they respond in a
coordinated effort so i think this also
tells us something more about the
the different processes that are going
on during different time points
there is a very important sort of
development in the field
of profit 19 immune response studies
which obviously relate
to the antibody response um it's
there's a great interest in
understanding
what determines the zero conversion and
the development of igg
antibodies to in this case the spike
protein the receptor binding domain of
the spike protein
and so we've looked at the antibody
levels
in these same patients and we see that
almost all of the patients
have a pretty clear tighter increase
in their igg antibodies against this
receptive binding domain of the white
protein and
we've also assessed what immune
features cells and proteins in the blood
correlate or are related to this and the
way we did this was by devising a mixed
effects model
which takes days from admission into
account as a fixed effect
so this correlation is not merely due to
the correlations that i'm showing here
on the right are not
merely due to changes that um coincide
in time
because time is taken into account so
so what we're seeing here is that high
levels of infrared gamma and are
fixed and cxl10 which are related
pro-inflammatory cytokines those are
inversely
um those are negatively associated with
the unsupported response suggesting that
very strong inflammatory responses are
you know not good for uh for this
development of the antibody response we
also know that this is associated with
liver depletion and so perhaps
you lose a lot of your b cells and
plasma cells
um on the other hand we see that
basophil levels
both the cd16 expressing and then the
16 negative ones they are
positively associated with with the
optical response and that's been shown
also in other infections such as
influenza
that basophils can modulate and even
potentiate
b-cell responses so we find that to be
intriguing
to in 2019 as a final
section here final part of this analysis
was
we wanted to try to understand as i've
mentioned previously the natural course
of disease without any
immunomodulatory therapy patients were
also
not given antivirals in this study and
so this is really
representing the natural course when
patients are only treated by supportive
care
ventilatory support oxygen and so on
and what we were able to find was that
all of these patients
basically follow the same trajectory
there's clearly differences in the
speed the kinetics but also um
but the direction is pretty pretty much
the same
and one way to show that is what i'm
showing you here
what we're doing here is we're
integrating the measurements
of plasma proteins and cell populations
so both the old link data and the mass
cytometry data
and we're looking for shared latent
factors that explain
in this case changes over time
from acute to recovery
and we found that this latent factor too
is a is a factor that really
describes the changes that occur
from the acute phase to the recovery and
as you can see
all of the patients basically move
towards the top right corner where the
recovered patients sit and and
and so this we think gives us a
sort of integrated trajectory
that all patients need to follow during
their phase of recovery
and and what mediates this is
when we're looking at the loadings or
the proteins and cells
that change mostly along this latent
factor too
we see that this is primarily associated
with the decrease in the il-6 level
the levels of mcp3 and these other
plasma proteins such as ile
and so on that are listed here and
there's
it's also associated with an increase in
monocytes
both classical and non-classical as well
as
increase in eosinophils and gametophyte
cells
so they fulfilled as well so we
we think that this represents a
integrated trajectory of recovery
which might be possible to monitor
patients
to better understand whether a patient
is
on the verge of recovery or whether the
patient
is deteriorating in the disease
so this concludes the presentation with
the
of this study where we've performed the
systems level immuno monitoring analysis
from acute to recovery phase
of severe kobe 19 patients for more
details please
make sure to check out this preprint
that is on metaarchive
also i would like to i think we've
uncovered several co-regulated cell
populations and
and immune features over the course of
the disease
we've described some correlates of
productive antibody responses as well as
uncovered
a trajectory of recovery from acute
to recovery phases of the disease
um i would like to highlight all these
co-authors who have contributed to this
very quick
study both in my lab at the karolinska
institute
as well as the clinical center in
helsinki as well as the university of
health
so with that i'll thank you for your
attention and be happy to take any
questions